I think he's an amoral psychopath I
think he is crude evil vicious and
vindictive drunk hi I'm Nick Gillespie
with Reason TV and today we're sitting
down with Roger stone the well-known
political operative and the author most
recently of a fascinating new book the
man who killed Kennedy the case against
LBJ Roger thanks for talking to us great
to be here so in the beginning of the
book you say you know to delve into the
Kennedy assassination and the 50th
anniversary is coming up in a few weeks
is to lay down with kook's and nuts why
are you doing this well you know the
whole term conspiracy theorist that's a
pejorative that's what the mainstream
media uses to denigrate anyone who
questions the government's version of
virtually anything I look I don't
believe that UFOs landed in Roswell New
Mexico I don't believe the attack on
America and 9/11 was an inside job I'm
really not a conspiracy guy so I'm not
talking conspiracy I'm talking facts and
I think Lyndon Johnson had unique motive
means and opportunity to to kill John
Kennedy and I think he participated in a
plot to do so okay it'll briefly outline
the case against LBJ you know one of the
things that is fascinating about the
book is that it's a rich compilation of
existing scholarship and kind of
resynthesize work about really the you
know kind of disastrous and awful
personalized but also political lives of
JFK as well as LBJ you tie LBJ to what
eight murder
eight murders prior to John F Kennedy at
least eight and I'm not including his
own sister who he may have killed okay
he's buried on that note I'll let what's
the case against okay first of all I
think I do think he's a serial murderer
I think that there is a long trail of
murders pertaining to the cover-up of
epic corruption I mean corruption of
biblical proportions I also think he
murdered to cover up vote threat theft
and fraud with which he got first got to
the United States Senate this I mean you
know what in on your ledger or near
favor I mean there's no question that he
rigged that election no question though
the landslide Lyndon a election yeah he
steals it with 87 fraudulent votes
people who voted in alphabetical order I
may
they all had the same handwriting and
they all signed in in the same ink so I
think that he is I think he's an amoral
psychopath I think he is crude evil
vicious vindictive
drunk you know one of the things that
it's genuinely fascinating about the
book is the way that you tie organized
crime to Nixon as well but especially
JFK and Lyndon Johnson in various ways
talk about Malcolm Wallace because he's
the guy that you say actually put the
bullet in into Kennedy's head sure
Malcolm Wallace is Lyndon Johnson's
personal hit man Malcolm Wallace has
gotten a long succession of federal
patronage jobs he works the Agriculture
Department and at the behest of Johnson
in 1951 he murders a man named John
Kinser who was intimately involved with
Johnson's sister Kinser is blackmailing
Johnson he murders Kinser in cold blood
in front of witnesses when he's
apprehended he tells the apprehending
officer you can't arrest me I have to
get back to Washington I work for
Senator Johnson he goes to trial for
first-degree murder he's defended by
Lyndon Johnson's personal attorney John
Cofer he is convicted he gets a
five-year suspended sentence and he
walks out a free man he is immediately
hired by a company called Temko a
defense contractor owned by a fellow
named HD Bird HD Bird also is one of the
major funding seers of LBJ's career he
also dabbles in real estate he owns the
Texas School Book Depository building
talk a little bit about you know one of
the things that's fascinating read
Kennedy assassination theory says that
you've always got everybody has to
hustle Lee Harvey Oswald off the stage
yes because Oswald is you know an
obvious you know gunman he's a marine he
defects to the Soviet Union he's a
Marxist he's a pro-castro guy right yeah
but he's there right there that day yes
he's definitely there but he's a patsy
he's the fall guy first of all his
communist background is fabricated we
now know based on the testimony of at
least two Secret Service agents that
he's trained by the by the apartments
he's trained by the CIA and a defector
program he goes to Russia
he's there he comes back he gets his
citizenship back like that even though
he's renounced that the American
government lends him five thousand
dollars and they
pay for his airfare let's talk a little
bit about this what changes but you know
what changes if we fully accept and kind
of internalized the idea that LBJ killed
John F Kennedy how does that change our
understanding of American politics of
history and of who we are as a nation
well obviously at this late date no one
is going to try Lyndon Johnson puss
methey and and and the convictive of
murder but I think if if my book
achieves nothing if it persuades people
that what the government tells you
cannot be believe that anything the
government tells you needs to be guarded
with a certain heavy dose of skepticism
then I will have accomplished something
important ok and this is published by
skyhorse books which publishes a wide
range of things some are in the
conspiracy frame Jesse Ventura is one of
their authors they do other kinds of
various things you're going to be doing
more books with them talk a little bit
about your future yeah there I've got a
couple different books in mind I'd like
to do a book on I'd like to do a book on
Hillary Clinton I don't believe Chelsea
Clinton I believe Chelsea Clinton is the
daughter of web Hubbell and Hillary
Clinton and I'm going to try to prove
that in print ok well that you know
onward and upward yeah so thank you
Roger stone the new book is the man who
killed Kennedy the case against LBJ it
is a fascinating read like I said I'm
not fully persuaded but I enjoyed every
page and I've been flipping back and
forth through it so thank you very much
Roger thanks for having me for a reason
TV I'm Nick Gillespie